Glow in the Dark Urine... and 8 Other Animal
Facts
1.
The “Hercules beetle” lives in the rainforests
of Central and South America and is known
for being able to lift more than 850 times
its own weight, or about 8 kilograms (17.6
lbs).
Pound for pound, this makes it one of the
strongest animals on the planet.
For reference, if a 90 kg (200 lb) male human
could do the same, he would be able to lift
76,500 kg or 170,000 lbs.
(QF: 721)
2.
Cats are the only known animal, including
humans, that prefer to be given things freely,
rather than needing to do some task to get
them.
Don’t believe us?
Google Contrafreeloading if you’re interested
in learning more.)
(QF: 445)
3.
Wombat poop is cubic.
(QF: 455)
4.
Hippopotamus kill more people in Africa than
any other large animal, including more than
lions, crocodiles, and elephants.
(QF 497)
5.
Wild American bison, often incorrectly called
buffalo, are one of the most dangerous animals
to encounter in the United States.
In Yellowstone National Park alone, nearly
five times as many people are killed by bison
than by bears every year.
The bison can reach speeds of up to 35 miles
per hour and are surprisingly nimble, making
them difficult to avoid if they attack, which
they do with little provocation.
6.
The testes of the Right whale are the largest
of any animal, each weighing around 500 kg
(1,100 lb).
7.
Animals such as dogs, rabbits, rodents, gorillas,
etc. often eat their poop to maintain proper
health.
For animals like rabbits, who eat a lot of
plants, their poop contains quite a bit of
undigested plant matter; so eating their poop
is a nice easy way to get more out of the
food they have available.
For other animals, like dogs, their poop can
also be very vitamin rich with the bacteria
in their intestines producing essential vitamins
they wouldn’t get otherwise.
Dogs particularly like cat poop because it
is very high in protein.
8.
Mouse urine glows under florescent light.
Further, despite their propensity to spread
disease and the like, surprisingly, mice are
very clean animals.
They clean themselves regularly, not unlike
cats, and they organize their homes with specific
areas for storing food, going to the bathroom,
sleeping, etc.
9.
The Honeyguide is a type of bird that will
lead certain animals, most notably the Honey
Badger, to beehives.
The bird will then wait for the Honey Badger
to break open the beehive and to have its
fill.
Once the Honey Badger has left, the Honeyguide
will fly in and eat the leftover larvae and
beeswax.
Honeyguides are also known to lead humans
to honey, again so that they can feed on the
scraps left behind.
The Boran people even use a special type of
whistle to try to attract a Honeyguide when
they want
to search for honey.